robert says i know you hate talking
about roi but how do you show someone
there's a true return on your efforts on
social media
how do you set the question up again
i know you hate talking i know you hate
talking about roi yeah but how do you
show someone that there's a true return
on your efforts robert i love you for
this question drock definitely edited
this out and make it one question it's
called roi of your mother part two
because i want to put this right to bed
once and for all the arrow of your
mother concept is to make fun of
traditional media roi not to get away
from social media roi i robert i i love
to talk about the roi of social media i
don't want to run away from it i'm all
in on it once and for all i want to talk
about this i love roi i sell stuff it's
what i do nothing matters to me
otherwise no marketing media reports no
rewards no ad age mentions that's not
what i play for i want to sell coffee i
want to sell cheese i want to sell wine
i want to sell gadgets i want to sell
sweaters i want to sell you if you let
me that's how i roll and so
how do you prove it you prove it meaning
there's a lot of ways to do it i don't
know what you're trying to sell and i
know a lot of brand managers from big
brands kind of follow me and watch me
here i
i it's very easy to prove the roi of
social media when we post the t-shirt
that we want to sell let's link that up
by the way i never got around to posting
t-shirts so now it's 20 bucks not 14 the
reverse engineer thing i apologize
vaynernation uh
we see the sales
when i post when we run dark posts for
wine library we see the sales when we
ran that campaign for that one
organization we got 2 400 signups versus
the 60 signups they got for doing
youtube videos and billboards and all
that and they spent 10 times more there
it is very easy my friend if
you have the direct channel connect what
i mean by that i don't know what that
meant it just spewed but if you can
prove it out on the back end so for
example let me explain for most of the
clients we work with when you're a cpg
company and you sell your product to
walmart and then they sell it it gets
hard to prove the roi of a post but when
you're gary vaynerchuk and you have
winelibrary.com and you post it and it
goes directly back to you you can see it
guys the only reason i have so much
bravado is i'm seeing the math i come
with bravado when i have intuition right
but i'm always hedging watch my
narrative i'm always like there's
something happening here look what i
just did with virtual reality i'm
nuancing it yes i'm making i'm hedging
but i'm still making a commitment but
the insanity that you've seen from me on
facebook dark posts or the emerging
insanity on pinterest's ad product once
it gets a little bit more price
effective and at scale that's nothing
you've seen from me since maybe 2009
crush it when i really believed in
youtube because i was feeling it guys
i'm feeling it right now how do you
prove the roi you create a connective
tissue to show you that this thing did
that now that's direct response selling
right that's dr and that's fine i'm a
branding guy you need a mix because if
you keep throwing right hooks it has
diminishing returns but it's never been
more easy to prove the roi of social
media than it is right now because you
can just link it directly to the dot com
attribution whereas you cannot do that
for print outdoor radio or television
you just can't you can't do it in the
same exact way you can create a call to
action in those commercials and you can
track it and you can and you will and
that's why those channels matter still
as well but it's very easy to put a link
in any piece of content even in
instagram where i put in my headline you
guys know what i'm talking about so
you know misnomer i do like talking
about the roi of social media i just
don't like that it's not understood that
it's more obvious to track it than it is
in traditional and more importantly i
don't want to talk
turn
turn all of you into direct response
sellers because then you're far too much
right hooking and so a lot of times the
best pieces of content are engaging and
jabbing where there is no link out to a
call to action so there's a drop in the
correlation of sales but you're doing
the better overall thing for the brand
my friends it's branding and marketing
not just sales but social media can show
you sales oh crap wait subscribe
i need subscriptions because i can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe